president trump once again calling on
schools to reopen
tweeting democrats open the schools
safely now
when schools are closed let the money
follow the child the family
why should schools be paid when they are
closed they shouldn't
this comes as a new york high school
student is arrested after showing up to
class on a day he was assigned to learn
remotely the teen already had been
warned and suspended for showing up to
school
when he was supposed to be taking
classes from home
the student not planning on backing down
i intend on continuing to make my voice
heard until that
the the administration decides that they
can't ignore it anymore
and we get to go to school five days a
week
the school district says the student was
violating their corona virus safety
protocols
and they add quote mr stowe continues to
display irresponsible
and selfish behavior with today's latest
publicity stunt
mr stowe's rights as a student do not
surpass the rights
of any of our other 8 800 students
kennedy what do you say to that i mean i
i
does his i mean the the rules of the
school district clearly supersede any
any desire from any one student wouldn't
you agree
um yeah but i i bet there are also
plenty of students at his school
who are learning remotely and not
having any in-person attendance at all
and that is the choice that most parents
in new york state have been given we've
been given survey after survey
what would you prefer in-person learning
or
a blend or complete digital
online learning and for some families
they don't want to take the risk
you may have generations living together
at home and they don't want their
students in school
if that's the case in this school and
you have one kid who wants to go five
days a week
and others are not attending then let
him go maybe he has a crush on a cute
girl right
[Laughter]
hey jesse uh i i'm
asking you this uh with tongue-in-cheek
but i think you're gonna know the answer
when you're suspended from school jesse
you can't go to school right
theoretically juan
but here's the thing okay this kid is a
legend
he gets suspended the first week of
school
and then he gets arrested mug shot
and then he tips off the media to film
him being arrested
total pro he gets booked on fox news
celebrity like his mom's not even mad at
him
this kid's next level when you think
about what's going on here
his college essay's written itself
i want to learn so badly i am willing to
go to
jail for it this kid's going places i
don't know about you he's either going
to be a politician
a reality star or a fox news host to be
honest one i'm worried my job's not safe
oh my gosh oh my gosh greg uh
you know he threatened that he would
have to be forcibly
removed so that got the of course the
school authorities up in arms what do
you say to somebody who says
you're going to have to pull me out of
here what do you expect when you name
your kid
maverick i mean
anyway i'm a little suspicious i'm a
little suspicious of what's going on
here i'm not a big fan the way jesse is
but i hear i'm going to go back to my
old saw i'm rooting for innovation the
elon musks of the world
must use covet as an opportunity to
remake education
i was doing a little bit of research
technology has revolutionized
everything but education you know before
there was movies
and recorded music entertainment
consisted of basically
touring shows of like burlesque
vaudeville minstrels
and the actors were pretty low on the
totem pole they weren't famous or
or nobody cared about them but then they
were elevated to stardom because of
movies and then music and television and
it was because the screen did it
technology did it
and imagine that kind of effect on
education
that if you were a charismatic talented
teacher that was elevated to a screen
in which millions of students watched
you how cool would that job become
and how much better and efficient
education would be
if again we married technology to
education
because right now this is incr this is
an incredible time waster
to teach a million algebra classes a day
all right so dana you know i i believe
in your right to raise your voice to say
when you think something's wrong but if
you
break the laws then of course they're
going to be consequences and in this
case uh he
clearly broke the school district in the
school's laws
so how do you feel about his actions
i feel like we have a young man who is
practicing
peaceful protesting and civil
disobedience
and he got arrested he didn't make a big
fuss he didn't
burn anything down he didn't loot any
stores
didn't cause any more problems just
exercising
his way to express himself and there
were consequences for it
he broke the law you have to get
arrested and as jesse said he'll have
stories to tell for the rest of his life
all right